AMIR ELAQUIZY: Cratejoy
is an ecommerce platform
for building your own
subscription business.
So if you're familiar with
Birchbox or the Dollar Shave
Club, Cratejoy allows you,
a non-technical person,
to create your own website
where people can sign up, buy
products on a
subscription basis,
and you can ship it
out and delight them
every single month.
We are building tools
which other people use
for their business, which
means it has to work.
There's just no exceptions.
And bells and whistles are
cool, but the second one
of those bells or whistles
detracts from them actually
making money with their
business, you look really dumb.
So we actually-- although
our merchant portal
is heavily JavaScripted
and Ajax-y and really cool
and I like it a lot--
our stores, which
are what the merchant-- their
business faces the customers,
those have very
little JavaScript.
We actually stripped out almost
all the dynamic components,
especially from
the checkout flow.
It is possible to make that
stuff very robust and very
high functioning, but we
needed time to get that done,
and we hadn't had that time yet.
So stripping it all out,
our merchants actually
significantly improved
their conversion rates,
their overall
platform happiness.
And now we can slowly introduce
that stuff one at a time.
Make it a little bit easier
to automatically figure out
their sales tax rates by calling
to the server and Ajaxing it,
or detect when they've
typo'd of their address.
We can add those
things one at a time
and in a controlled
fashion roll them out.
And the merchants are
happy because we're not
degrading the experience at
all So for us, it was actually
stripping out
functionality and adding it
back in in a controlled fashion.